[Music]
from the openings title splash screen
sonic manias presentation is
intoxicating it's colorful retro 2d
graphics and vibrant 90s inspired pop
soundtrack is enough to make any Sega
Genesis fans squeal and excitement but
Sonic's latest outing isn't only
concerned with reminding you of his
golden years Sonic mania exceeds
expectations what a new game in the
franchise can play and look like
managing to simultaneously be a charming
celebration of the past and a natural
progression of the series's classic 2d
formula
[Music]
sonic mania makes a strong first
impression thanks to amazing visuals and
music its presentation replicates the
charming aesthetic of Sonic's earliest
games with thorough detail the new
sprite animations add an extra layer of
personality to the iconic characters
that's a joy to see in motion the game
also sports an assortment of new music
tracks and remixes of greatest hits that
are incredibly catchy and well
orchestrated
[Music]
both visuals and music work together in
Sonic mania to build an aesthetic that's
evocative of earlier games but in a
pleasing style that feels contemporary
all on its own on top of Sonic manias
fantastic presentation the game also
controls like a classic style Sonic game
you have the option to play as sonic
tails or knuckles from the get-go the
movement physics and overall feel of
each character or distinct yet familiar
staying faithful to the originals the
gang's unique abilities remain intact
albeit with one exception Sonic has a
new drop - which allows him to quickly
roll forward after a jump it's a small
addition but it provides a handy new way
to pick up speed or avoid incoming
danger level design is that the series
is best here
sporting 12 zones that are each
meticulously designed with cleverly
placed obstacles and varied pathways
that keep you guessing and thanks to the
visibility granted by the widescreen
aspect ratio and the smooth frame rate
your awareness and sense of control
running through zone feels better than
Sonic's classic outings ever did it also
helps that levels are designed around
the abilities of each character while
Sonic can blaze a trail through a zone
knuckles and Tails can find other paths
beyond his reach thanks to the
respective climbing and flying abilities
which often lead to new ways of
experiencing the same stage and you're
rewarded for taking the time to play
them as on some occasions they even get
completely new zones to explore that are
designed specifically around their
abilities
[Music]
sonic mania closely follows in the
exhilarating sense of speed of its
forebears however it expands upon the
familiar with new ideas of its own this
is most apparent when you play remixed
versions of older zones from the first
five games for example sonic manias
version of Sonic 2 s chemical plant zone
introduces a mechanic where you
constantly jump on jelly to bounce
upwards to new parts of the level
changes like this liven up the design of
well-known levels offering fresh and
gratifying new experiences new zones
deliver plenty of inventive concepts
that diversify and build upon the
series's fast-paced level design whether
it's by encouraging you to freeze
yourself into an ice block to smash
through walls or challenging you to
figure out a maze-like sequence of gates
to reach the end of a zone the ideas the
game explorers give it a strong sense of
identity compared to the originals every
level culminates in a boss fight ranging
from relatively simple to demanding
set-piece battles where you go
head-to-head with Eggman and his minions
one has you dodging projectiles as you
use a series of poles to propel yourself
towards a spider robot
[Music]
phosphites offer great balance of
difficulty steadily challenging and
entertaining you in numerous ways as you
progress the more you play Sonic mania
the more it rewards you with reasons to
keep playing but one of the most
compelling reasons to plays owns comes
from Secrets sonic manias term for
unlocks that give you access to new
characters and abilities for example you
can play through the entire campaign
using the Sonic 3 into the shield
ability however the caveat is that you
can only turn on secrets when playing
without save functionality so if you
want to use these abilities you can only
do so by going through the game in one
sitting
it's a strange limitation that restricts
your ability to take advantage of
everything the game has to offer
[Music]
for years the Sonic series has chased
the legacy of its early games repeatedly
delivering experiences that either came
close or failed to recapture the spirit
that made them classics sonic mania
methodically uses its sentimental appeal
to great effect but in the process it
heals the wounds inflicted by its most
disappointing predecessors and surpasses
the series is best with its smart and
interpretive design an excellent 2d
platformer Sonic mania goes beyond
expectations managing to not only be a
proper evolution of the series's iconic
formula but the best Sonic game ever
made
[Music]